over the last decade
it has been a conservative mission to
promote tax cuts for working people and
simplify the system
that's why
that's why conservative-led governments
raised their income tax personal
allowance from six and a half thousand
pounds in 2010 to the new level of 12
570 pounds
but the equivalent thresholds in
national insurance which define how much
people can earn knicks free
are still around three thousand pounds
less
now the prime minister pledged in the
2019 election
we would increase those
thresholds we made a big step towards
that goal in my first budget in 2020
increasing the national insurance
threshold to 9
500 pounds
today
we take the next
step our current plan
is to increase the next threshold this
year
by 300 pounds
but i'm not going to do that mr speaker
i'm going to increase it by the full 3
000
delivering our promise to fully equalize
the nips and income tax thresholds and
not incrementally over many years but in
one go this year
from this july people will be able to
earn twelve thousand five hundred and
seventy pounds a year without paying a
single penny of income tax on national
insurance
that is a 6 billion pound personal tax
cut for 30 million people across the
united kingdom
a tax cut for employees worth over
330 pounds a year
the largest increase in a basic rate
threshold ever
and this largest single personal tax cut
in a decade
[Applause]
[Music]
the institute
the institute for fiscal studies has
called it the best way to help low and
middle earners through the tax system it
creates what the center for policy
studies has called a universal working
income it is a tax cut that rewards work
[Music]
and mr speaker
mr speaker
a horse artillery
of all workers
will have their taxes cut by more than
the amount they'll pay through the new
levy
once again showing it is this
conservative government delivering for
hard-working families and helping with
the cost of living